[Music]  my angle stranger things is back to turn  our worlds upside down  Netflix dropped the season 2 trailer  during the Superbowl and if this new  footage is any indication we're in for  one seriously intense ride looks like  the monster who terrorized our favorite  Hawkins Indiana residents will meet the  entire town on a much larger scale do  you know where he is stranger things  season 2 will be available to binge this  Halloween but to hold you over here's  what the show creators recently teased  2et  barb will not be forgotten in season 2 I  will say that much that there will be a  lot of talk about barb she is still dead  though I know you've got some stellar  talent added to the roster sean astin  what can you tell us about that he's  just an incredible actor and he's just  he blows us away every day on set is  incredible Bob any words at radio tech  [Music]